that's Hunter College educator who held
a machete up to reporter's neck now
crying victimhood after getting arrested
Shelly and Rodriguez went viral after
hurling fouled mouth and abuse and
pro-life students she then threatened to
chop up a New York Post reporter with
the machete Fox News shares common
ownership with the New York Post she
lost her job at Hunter College but she
complains the school has quote
capitulated to racist white nationalists
and misogynists oh my God
Greg yes she went up to the man with a
knife she should have been arrested on
the spot it's very she she did turn
herself in
but it was racist to go
arrest her you know Lawrence it's hard
for me to sit here and listen to you uh
say these things about this woman who
clearly is a victim anybody who objects
to somebody trying to kill you with a
machete has to be a bad evil racist uh
from now on you must Embrace any machete
Wilding person or you are a machete
phobe it's weird though it's like we're
in a society now where we have to uh
denigrate citizens while holding up
people that try to harm you whether it's
criminals then they're being recast as
like victims and in this case her you
look at her and you read about her and
you realize she's been getting away with
it forever right for so long and why
because she's terrified people and how
she exploits nice scared cowardly white
folks who don't want to appear racist
and they don't want to cross her that's
for sure but you know what she crossed
the line if that wasn't on tape with the
machete this would never have been a
problem you needed to finally get her
actions on tape and why does she even
need a machete I mean she she has said
we don't need police we don't need
police so is this machete for protection
you know who's she protecting herself
from I don't know large I don't know
cucumbers I don't know what do you use a
machete for anyway Dana this all started
because of free speech this is a poll 90
of Coliseum thinks it's okay to use
violence against controversial speaking
well the thing is she only got arrested
after she used the machete yes or fire
excuse me fired fired after she used the
machete against the reporter I think she
should have been fired when she was
walked by peacefully
peaceful students they're not even
protesting they had pamphlets and
brochures for information you can see it
there and she yelled abuse at them is
this the kind of Professor that you want
around your students I would have fired
her for that instead she uses all of
that language because her Union is
backing her up she'll probably figure
out a way to stay within the system
somehow her getting arrested might help
her end up with a podcast Harold she's
still employed at another College
they're reviewing the situation
it may not be a whole lot to review
after after what what we we're looking
at and what we're saying she has mental
health challenges also and I hope that
she gets in all seriousness I think I
hope she gets to some of the the help
she may need two I'm one that firmly
believes that the sin is a powerful and
important characteristic of an enduring
democracy and we've talked about it when
I I've agreed with things that some have
not not on this show but we've covered
stories you we can't coddle this if you
have students out peacefully uh
projecting a set of views that you
disagree with whether you're a professor
or student you have no right to behave
like that and Dana's right you would
fire her from this job and another job
in an academic institution not because
of her views but because of the way she
the way she behaved here so I wish her I
hope she gets the help that she needs
and I hope that that no student has to
be around that okay here's the thing why
okay why is it that whenever somebody
does something that that we can't
comprehend we say oh they have mental
problems no maybe they're just just mean
maybe they're just evil and I love the
way you say you know dissent is
certainly endearing part of our
democracy it's important prosecution is
more so an endearing part of our
democracy so people like that with
machetes not only that are not able to
put it up to your neck chase you out of
the building chased you down the street
saying Fu I'm gonna chop you up and then
kick him in the Shins and by the way for
those kids at the college this is a
problem with people on the right we're
too polite don't let somebody tell you
you know you can't say this you can't
say that you know you can go back at her
she has no right to damage your pro your
pamphlets so she isn't just terrifying
people the woman's a bully I'd like to
know how she got arrested in the first
place by the way she's already suing the
police you know she's not not so she's
already suing the police and she has a
tattoo on no I'm not finished she has a
tattoo on her on her hand that says F
the police okay
across the country yeah thank you that's
what you your parents are paying for
right there Hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now